that's got to be the best pirate i've
ever seen yo
ho welcome to a pirate's life nobody
expected pirates of the caribbean curse
of the black pearl to be as big of a hit
as it was
the film led to four highly successful
sequels
johnny depp became one of the biggest
stars in hollywood playing jack sparrow
and revitalized the modern day
blockbuster
today we're setting sail and finding out
what
exactly went into making the pirates of
the caribbean
curse of the black pearl so i'd be
having that dress back before you get
them
the scene which finds kira knightley's
elizabeth swann walking the plank
took two days to film nightly recalls
being terrified but when the crew told
her they could use a stunt double for
when her character jumps off the plank
she responded by saying i was like i've
been standing up here for two days do
you really think that i'm not gonna jump
off this
thing among one of the many reasons why
johnny depp was cast in the role of
captain jack sparrow was that the studio
felt that he already had the vibe of a
modern day pirate
in order to retain a look that was still
in touch with the film setting the
makeup artist had to get
creative when covering depp's personal
tattoos so they used such smears and
costumes to cover several of his tattoos
and would proceed to add new pirate
themed ones depp did keep one of his
pirate tattoos
which was jack sparrow's own name which
stepped kept to both honor the character
as well as his son who was born the year
before the release of the film
the code is more what you call
guidelines than actual rules
welcome aboard the black pearl joffrey
rush
was so committed to mastering the art of
sword fighting
that the crew became sick of dealing
with him depp was also committed to the
craft
and developed jack sparrow's flamboyant
fighting style which was inspired by the
famous muhammad ali
his method involved keeping his arms
down and letting his opponent come to
him
bootstrap
several contact lenses were made to help
show off mackenzie crook's rigetti's
wooden
eye with a hard lens used to make his
eye bulge even more
lee ornenberg's pintel also had contact
lenses that were used to make his eyes
look extremely yellow
joffrey rush had contact lenses that
made his eye colors less bright and more
dull so he'd appear more sickly as
barbosa even johnny depp
had contact lenses that doubled as
sunglasses that would help him not
squint during long days of filming in
the sun hey it's clean it's not supposed
to be clear
the curse of the black pearl already had
quite the elaborate wardrobe and prop
department the process of casting jack
sparrow's fellow pirate and prisoner
extras was definitely a unique process
the process involved bringing in around
600 bikers
and out of work actors into a basement
at disney and giving them real weapons
to work with
after people started getting hurt they
switched to rubber ones
on top of that there were 900 wardrobe
pieces in total
the clothes from the film initially
arrived clean and put together
it wasn't actually until the costume
design team had to work hard to make the
clothes appear far
dirtier than they originally were the
cave set
is one of the largest sets built on a
stage in hollywood
one of the film's biggest and most
extravagant sets is the treasure cave in
the film's third act
this set alone took well over five
months to build
with 100 craftsmen working to make the
set look as good as possible
i almost have a dot to not see those
dots
nearly 50 makeup artists worked on the
film often teeming with some of the
hairstylist
the film's makeup process of grunging up
each actor was also a different process
that required the team to apply the
makeup and prosthetics in layers
and was stippled on each cast member
with a brush instead of a sponge
there were days on set where up to 30 or
40 hairdressers would
work on the film's large ensemble of
principal actors as well as the extras
the hairdressers would have to work on
every single cast member from the
townsfolk to the british guard
to of course the pirates themselves it
was like an assembly line process
with all the casts having to take a seat
that was open in either the makeup
corner or the hair stylist corner
but that's a gamble of llamas
there's never a guarantee of coming back
obviously
a pirate really isn't a pirate without
rotting teeth
the teeth were mainly just colors which
meant that the makeup crew never had to
worry about touching up or continuously
checking on the actor's teeth
i'd say the most difficult thing was
just remembering all of the moves
in terms of the sword fights no pirate
movie is complete without some
badass sword fights the cast of curse of
the black pearl needed to learn how to
sword fight in order for the fight
scenes to look as stylized
and authentic as possible the cast was
topped by hollywood legend bob anderson
the military fort that nightly swan
faints off of in the film
was an actual practical set that was
built on location
in palos verdes california though the
shot that shows her fainting and making
her impact into the ocean
was shot in the caribbean where a
majority of the filming took place
but thank you you're welcome
not you we named the monkey jack the
scene where joffrey rushes captain
barbosa reveals to jack sparrow that his
pet monkey is also named jack
with the monkeys shooting a mockish
smile that was completely coincidental
the monkey smile wasn't actually planned
but performed the action at just the
right time
to make for the memorable shot the very
first shot of the film that features a
pirate ship coming out of the fog
wasn't actually just one shot like it
appeared to be
in fact the opening shot was really five
shots stitched together
to look like it was one take on top of
that despite this being one of the very
first scenes the crew shot
it wasn't finished until two days before
the film had its world premiere at
disneyland
captain jack sparrow if you please well
i didn't see your ship
captain while most of the film ships
were built from scratch
the hms interceptor wasn't instead
a real ship named lady washington was
used for the boat
the crew had to repaint the entire ship
having to manually cut out ports for the
cannons
and even change the stern among other
things
in order to design the pirates walking
corpses the crew used turkey jerky
as an influence to design the rotting
flesh in order to make the zombie
pirates distinguishable from each other
the designers decided to keep the actual
eyes of each pirate extra
that is without doubt the worst pirate i
have ever seen
the pirate genre had been dormant for
many years after the swashbuckling film
cutthroat island
turned out to be a box office flop
writers ted elliott and terry rossio
had been wanting to make a pirate themed
movie with a supernatural twist
since the early 90s and decided to pitch
it to disney
the mouse house was certainly hesitant
at first but decided to make the script
into an adaptation of their popular
theme park ride
pirates of the caribbean steven
spielberg was at one point
attached to direct the film before gore
verbrinsky a year prior to the release
another film based on a disney theme
park attraction was released
in the form of the country bears the
film was an unmitigated critical and
financial disaster
so much so that disney head michael
eisner
feared that the concept of a film based
on a theme park ride
would no longer work eisner tried to
shut down the film
but ferbinsky told his team to continue
to work on the film
after eisner was shown concept art for
the film he ultimately decided to let
verbinski move forward with the film
you are without doubt the worst pirate
i've ever heard of
but you have heard of me before johnny
depp was cast in the iconic role of jack
sparrow
the creative team actually had other
actors in mind
the role was actually written with hugh
jackman in mind
matthew mcconaughey robert de niro jim
carrey christopher walken and carrie
ellis
were also looked at to possibly take on
the role of the famed pirate
eisner was initially not a fan of depp's
portrayal of
jack sparrow and was most confused about
the character's personality
eisner was so pessimistic that he
thought def's eccentric performance
would sink the whole movie because
audiences wouldn't be able to get behind
the character
this prediction turned out to be far
from the truth as depp was so
universally praised for his performance
that he even earned an
oscar nomination for best actor much
like the casting of jack sparrow
there were plenty of actors in
consideration for the role of will
turner
with it finally being narrowed down
between ledger and
orlando bloom ultimately the team went
with bloom
i saved your life you say mine was
square depp
claims that the look mannerisms and
partying lifestyle of captain jack
sparrow were inspired by rolling stone's
guitarist
keith richards depp said that the main
reason he chose richards
was because he saw pirates as the rock
stars of their day
and felt that richards perfectly
captured that aura
kira knightley was coming off the indie
hit bend it like beckham
when she did the very first pirates
movie in fact
she was only 17 years old at the time of
filming nine years younger than her love
interest orlando bloom
because of her young age nightly's
mother had to accompany her throughout
the entire
shoot nightly even packed light fearing
that she would be fired early into the
shoot
and then got offered it and here i am
and i kind of thought every single day
that i was going to be fired
much of the film was shot on location in
the caribbean which led to the cast and
crew
making their way to set each day by boat
after one night of shooting on one of
the main islands
a boat that was carrying kira knightley
and her mother hit a reef and sank
while no one on board was injured the
mother and daughter were stuck
waiting for several hours before they
were eventually rescued
from then on night shoots were instead
filmed indoors in a studio
perhaps should be able to conjure up
another miraculous escape
pirates of the caribbean curse of the
black pearl was a
big risk by disney that paid off in the
best way
launching one of the biggest franchises
in hollywood history
what was your favorite moment from curse
of the black pearl